india may be experiencing the world's
worst
outbreak of covert 19 but millions of
people
still turned out to elect regional
leaders in the state of west bengal on
monday
it's one of five states that has held
elections in recent weeks
despite the drastically rising number of
infections
hospitals across the country are facing
a critical shortage of beds and oxygen
the us and uk have responded by sending
life-saving medical supplies to india
we want to provide them all the support
because they're close friends
increasingly important partners but also
we need this kind of international
collaboration if we're going to get
through the pandemic we're not going to
be safe until we're all safe
once the aid arrives armed police are
deployed to escort the precious cargo
that says regional states accuse each
other of stealing oxygen
soldiers guard a newly opened covert 19
care centre in new delhi
there are 500 beds so far not enough for
the many family members who couldn't
get their loved ones admitted to
hospitals
even here people are being turned away
being told that they can only be
admitted
if they have a referral and have
pre-registered the center also says that
it can't accept those who are critically
ill
leaving many with nowhere else to go
as many people die because of a lack of
help prime minister narendra modi has
been criticized for allowing
the large political and religious events
to go ahead
that led to the government asking
twitter to take down dozens
of posts critical of its handling of the
pandemic
this stems primarily from the fact that
this government does not take
very kindly to criticism it's very
sensitive to criticism and also from the
desire
to try and control the narrative as days
have gone by this comment has come in
increasingly for criticism increasingly
from citizens
and also i made a i i may say from from
the court
on monday the madras high court in the
southern city of chennai said india's
election commission
is single-handedly responsible for the
second wave
of the coronavirus elizabeth paranam
jazeera
new delhi joining us from new delhi is
rajiv dasgupta chairman of the center of
social medicine
and community health at jnu many thanks
for speaking to us here on al jazeera
let me first touch on something we saw
there in elizabeth's
package you're a community health doctor
the fact that millions of people are
still turning out
uh to elect regional leaders today in
the state of west bengal
how damaging is that to the situation
we're seeing in india
in terms of coved
well as we know the election commission
has been trying to
enforce the the standard operating
procedures
but it's been an uphill task if we talk
of west bengal
what's worrying for west bengal at this
point
is a 20 plus positivity rate
uh and and that's that that really
implies that it is in an ascending
phase of the second wave and
and these these activities are certainly
going to have
a role in the transmission
so what do you think is going to happen
next are we going to see
the covert situation getting worse in
say the rural areas and move
out of the cities
well several states which are
predominantly rural
for example chhattisgarh or bihar
they are also reporting relatively high
uh our values uh and and our value above
one
implies an ongoing transmission so on an
average india's our value is 1.27
now virtually all states are above one
which means that we would need some more
time
for this to at least stabilize before it
slows down
so in short all states are in a rising
phase
there would be difference between the
rural areas and urban areas obviously
but if the if the experience from some
of the states
which is in rural areas seem to be
somewhat more affected now than in the
first phase
but that's something we need to watch
out for let's get into that more
uh because my understanding is there are
a number of different strains of the
virus in india
now as opposed to the first time covert
struck
you have the uk strain the south african
strain you also have this uh
mutant indian strain which strain is
causing
the most concern do you think
well the the federal government did well
to put together the consortium of ten
national level laboratories uh in end
december
so the uk strain was identified as early
as 28 december
the b1617 popularly uh the double mutant
but that's not really the
the the term to be encouraged uh
the 617 was identified in early february
so it is possible that these are linked
to
at least the initial rise in cases in
maharashtra and punjab which accounted
for
two pretty large states maharashtra
being the second most popular state
both accounting for anything between 75
to 80 percent of
daily new cases uh till about the end of
march or even early april along with
another
two or three um states which accounted
for about five percent
uh contribution each to the national new
cases
so in short it's most likely driven by
these new variants and and the other
issues such as
such as the election or the religious
congregations and so on
they came much later to be honest uh
so so therefore as in all countries
second sorry second waves are led by
uh emerging mutant forms
so now we are talking about vaccines
we're getting
india is getting a lot of help from the
international community
sending across shipments of either
oxygen or vaccines and so on
how effective are the vaccines going to
be against
all these different strains
that is something that the
vaccinologists and laboratory scientists
are engaged with at this point
two vaccines already in the program as
we know the third one
has received authorization the sputnik
from the
from the russian uh groups and
and the initial batch of the sputnik
vaccines are going to be directly
imported from russia
and inducted into the program so we
believe that
these three vaccines which will be
available in the program
two are already available and that would
be strengthened uh
would would certainly have a role in
contributing to building up
the population level immunity but that's
not really
the immediate term the immediate term
over the next few weeks
is about providing medical care and more
importantly seamless medical care
as the central government today
underscored many thanks for your time
rajib das gupta
chairman of the center social media and
community health at
jehu thank you